hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and I just
went and saw Godzilla sultan of Agrabah
no shit
Godzilla king of the monsters I was
walking to my theater and the theater
next to mine was playing Aladdin and I
really wanted to just go see that again
for the third time I've seen it twice
already
I can't be helped I will die alone on
this hill
I love the live-action remake of Aladdin
okay
Godzilla I don't really have much
history with Godzilla I remember seeing
the last one and it was okay pretty I
would say lackluster from what I can
remember of it which isn't very much I I
didn't feel like you got to know the
characters very well the main character
being Godzilla of course but it's a real
fine line in movies like this where you
either go too deep into character stuff
and we're just like whoa we're just
trying to watch some monsters fight or
you don't go deep enough and then it's
like well we don't care about any of you
well done so I was a little concerned
about that going in mostly I was just
hoping it was a fun monster movie I'm
not a giant fan of Godzilla or for that
matter King Kong or any of these big
monsters I think big giant things
fighting it's a cool concept just really
neat sometimes it looks great but I
don't know it's not a genre that I'm
really drawn to to be quite honest I
wanted to see Rocket Man or ma this week
a lot more than I want to see Godzilla
but it's the big one coming out people
been talking about it me included so I
felt like I had to kind of and I'll tell
you what I am pleasantly glad that I did
I think the casting of this was really
well done whoever the casting director
was ruled because there were so many
people in this that like I know but I
don't like know their names but I like
them like I know them enough and I enjoy
their performances across the board
everyone's performances were believable
as believable as they can be in a giant
monster fighting movie and they were
filled with hearts and it was
perfect they really hit it well where
you you know these characters enough to
care about them but not too much where
you're like okay but the monsters where
are the monsters where the fighting
monsters everything looked really pretty
there were definitely some moments
especially in some of the bigger fights
that were really dark cloudy difficult
to see but the fighting that you saw
clearly and the close-ups of the
monsters looked freaking awesome the CGI
earnest was really cool I am not often
bothered by CGI even if it's not amazing
CGI because I think if the characters
shine through and if the story shines
through then you get the gist of what's
trying to happen here and this one
looked beautiful to me again not a
wizard of CGI but it looks great I think
the one thing that was really lacking
was the the script was a little weak
there was some really really cheesy
lines that jamieferry you really come to
expect in a movie like this I feel like
I feel like you're going into Godzilla
and if there's not a line like let me
find it how many nukes do you have if
they're not saying something like that
then it isn't truly a giant fighting
monster movie you know what I mean but
there's a little too far there are some
choices the characters made and these
actors sold the crap out of it but some
choices that the characters were written
to say and make that did not make a
goddamn centimeter of a sense no sense
at all and also in these kind of deals
there's it's always the same thing it's
bad guys who do something really stupid
that's clearly a terrible idea and they
do it for power and I mean that's
basically the gist of this I'm not gonna
spoil anything in here but there's a
slight twist of like who the actual you
know bad guy seeking power is and kind
of what their motives are and then like
a good Redemption arc there I was it's a
- it's over two hours and we got an hour
in and I was like okay I enjoyed some
things for sure there's some certain
scenes especially the monsters fighting
and that I really enjoyed but it wasn't
like
really really grasping me until a
definitive moment in the middle of this
movie middle to you know closer to the
end where it just completely latched me
on it got me right in the heart
it was super heartfelt super action
heavy super it felt weighted and
important and earned and then from then
on out it was just wild fun it was so so
so so great after that scene if you see
it when you see it I think you'll be
able to know which one it is it's just
very like weighted and it feels
important and it gave importance to
everyone else's journey and story and I
really enjoyed that I wrote I made names
for all of the different monsters so let
me read them all to you right now big
ass month
Hercules monster spider bitch turtle
bitch scary elephant spicy bird and
reptile and robot spider bitch sorry I
forgot about robot spider again I didn't
really grow up because the only thing I
didn't remember from my childhood being
Godzilla related was this bath toy that
was just a plastic Godzilla and it had
like neon blue his little back spikes
you know the ones science and then that
was very much represented in this movie
and that was very exciting brought me
way back to great baths alright I can't
tell what's happening it's dark and
blurry but it is cool and I do like
what's happening it's very kind of
blurred in some of the action sequences
another thing I don't enjoy is like like
the crazy woman trope like this
character she's a lady and she lost her
son and she's crazy and that is kind of
heavily used and
the script of this and I didn't love it
again there's some cool redemption to
certain characters and I love that
actress a lot I think she's great I
think she plays an unlikable likeable
character very well and again the
casting was excellent I just the script
made these people do some very different
things than you would think that they
would do overall the monsters look
incredible it's a super well acted
incredibly well executed cheesy popcorn
flick but like what else was it gonna be
again when you have a line that says how
many nukes do you got that's the movie
that it is it wasn't anything more I
enjoyed it I thought it was good didn't
change my life but I definitely went in
wanting to see other movies today I
wanted to see Aladdin again or Rocket
Man or ma and I went to see this and I'm
glad that I did I was pleasantly
surprised last note all I'll touch upon
here is that there was one scene where
Godzilla comes straight up face to face
with our lead male actor and I just
wrote boop boop and Boo Boo's knows give
him the boot I think it would have gone
a lot better if you did I'm gonna give
this seven out of ten hair flips because
it was better than I thought it was an
enjoyable film and from what I can tell
it was a lot better than the previous
guy so that's for sure so seven all
right I'm gonna go edit try to avoid
spicy bird and spider bitch robots by
the bridge
scary elephant
okay see you guys next week
[Music]